I used to wear Jordans because they were
more comfortable and I could do more
casual settings with them a lot of
restaurants are like no athletic wear
that's annoying then it went through
this whole thing where I had to find the
best short the ones that I have have
back hooks on them so that I can hang
them too dry I've got an iPhone pocket
in there that's built in because I hate
having to sit and then you take it out
of your pocket like every time like it's
such a pain like there should be a
pocket for this everyone has one right
these are stretchy but not too stretchy
but they're stretching up that I can
lift in them I can squat in them but
like I could fit a water bottle in here
if I need it or I use my Nicorette
because I chew Nicorette so I just I'd
like always have the stuff that I I need
there